[Música]
dicen que las verdades absolutas no
existen
pero yo les traigo una
todos y cada uno de ustedes
se va a morir
y es cierto yo también pero es algo en
lo que no me gusta pensar de hecho es
algo en lo que a veces sintiendo a
convencerme que a mí no me va a pasar
y es por eso que desde niño empecé a
cuestionarme los conceptos no solo de
paraíso infierno porque se imaginan
pasar toda la eternidad recogiendo
margaritas o bueno como será en mi caso
toda la eternidad sufrir en el infierno
es algo que se me hace muy pero muy pero
muy aburrido
y ya no solo me cuestionaba los
conceptos de paraíso infierno sino
incluso el de dios mismo
pronto me encontré con el trabajo de
stephen hawking que decía que las leyes
de la naturaleza son suficientes que
dios no es necesario para mover el motor
del universo
en este punto empecé a considerarme
diagnóstico con todas las consecuencias
entre ellas entender que después de la
muerte ya no había nada
y me dije bueno al menos puedo hacer
algo en vida para trascender
escribe un libro me gustaba la música
aprendí a intentar componer sinfonías
hasta que me di cuenta de que en un
millón de años cuando la humanidad
desaparezca en él había un portal que en
formosa reto ven y pues que me quedaba a
mí
y es que desprovisto de la esperanza de
encontrar algo después de la muerte o te
puedes hacer algo en vida que me quedaba
llegué a la conclusión de que vivir
plenamente
era un maravilloso premio de consolación
vivir plenamente el problema es que
estas palabras se han tergiversado con
el tiempo porque si vamos con alguien y
le preguntamos oye a qué te dedicas
no nos va a contestar a vivir plenamente
gracias y tú
lo más probable es que nos contesten soy
doctor soy abogado
pero es que eso no se dedica en eso
trabaja
y es normal que ya hemos confundido
estos conceptos porque entre dormir y
trabajar pasamos el 50% de nuestro
tiempo y el otro 50 estaba en
actividades como comer ir al baño estar
triste estar enojado estar enamorado
estar enfermo
me empecé a hacer especialmente
consciente de esto cuando empezó a usar
tarjeta de crédito
porque hacía pequeños pagos y pequeños
pagos generación hasta final de mes que
decía wow como pude gastar tanto y es
que gastar es muy fácil cuando no somos
conscientes del flujo de dinero que está
corriendo
y lo mismo pasa con el tiempo vivir en
automático es muy fácil cuando no somos
conscientes del flujo de tiempo que está
corriendo
o más bien deberes is de tiempo porque
es como una dama hermosa pero veleidosa
dulce pero vengativa
como las damas la tiempo no nos va a
recriminar día a día las cosas que
hagamos se va a esperar a que estemos en
nuestro lecho de muerte para sacarnos
todo
y es que como a todas las damas no hay
que buscar comprenderla
porque no se puede hay que amarla
y como entendiendo que como uno también
tiene defectos y es que la tiempo tiene
todos grandes defectos
no se puede alargar seamos quienes
seamos y hagamos lo que hagamos todos
tenemos años de 365 días y días de 24
horas
y defecto número 2 no se puede apresurar
dicen que la paciencia es una virtud y
yo agregaría que es la virtud de los
dioses
porque los dioses no tienen tiempo pero
nosotros mortales sí que lo tenemos y es
por eso que defino madurez como el hecho
de entender qué cosas personas y
especialmente el tiempo no están ahí a
nuestra disponibilidad
el tiempo no busca cortar nuestras
tristezas y alargar nuestras felicidades
el tiempo sigue su propio ritmo y es
justamente aceptando estos defectos que
podemos pasar de tener una relación
tóxica con la tiempo a tener una
relación sana
de estas que nos van a permitir no sólo
vivir plenamente sino incluso dar un
paso más
porque si bien es cierto que no podemos
trascender por la eternidad si puedes no
superar día a día
platón decía que el tiempo es la imagen
móvil de la eternidad
los seres humanos somos capaces de soñar
y la manera de superarnos es justamente
materializando dichos sueños
pero una vez muy sorprendido conmigo
mismo porque aunque dicen que la gota de
agua rompe la roca no por su fuerza sino
por su persistencia
yo mismo año con año bajo los mismos 12
sonidos comiendo las mismas 12 frutas
pedí a los mismos 12 deseos y aún así
nunca los cumplían
y creo que eso pasa porque muchas veces
el contexto es más fuerte que el
concepto porque si lo admito
conceptualmente no tengo muchos sueños y
metas y deseos pero mi contexto
agarrarlos hace bolitas los pies a la
basura
el concepto por ejemplo es bajar la
pancita el contexto es que comprar una
hamburguesa es más rápido más fácil y de
todos modos de dónde vamos a sacar
tiempo para cocinar algo sano
el concepto es aprender un nuevo idioma
el contexto es encontrar tiempo para
memorizar 10.000 nuevas palabras
el concepto de ciudad el gimnasio el
contexto es que está 2 kilómetros pero a
50.000 horas gracias al tráfico
y me puse a pensar bueno cómo puedo
vencer entonces a este concepto
y eureka descubrir el agua tibia hay
tres elementos que todos conocemos que
nos ayudan a materializar sueños
tiempo dinero y esfuerzo
el dinero lo admito es el factor que
siempre ha falta
pero también el que siempre se puede
intentar cortejar ya sea trabajando un
poco más siguiendo a un presupuesto para
gastar menos y si no ya te plano con un
crédito y cuesta es cierto pero
justamente son estos sacrificios los que
dan valor a nuestros sueños
después ven y el esfuerzo y pronto me di
cuenta que no era esfuerzo físico porque
nadie le piden ser súper fuerte por allá
del gimnasio de hecho esa es la meta
hacen falta ganas honestas de querer
mejorar nuestra salud
a nadie se le pide ser super genio para
seguir estudiando
hacen falta ganas honestas de querer
seguir aprendiendo y es que el esfuerzo
entonces es una decisión y las
decisiones siempre siempre siempre
dependen de uno mismo
procuramos con el tiempo
la ley de la cadena entera
administrativa dice que la fuerza de un
equipo se determina por su integrante
más débil
y el tiempo como ya dijimos
es limitado y por tanto es limitante
pero limitante de que a quién
porque una vez me encontré con la
biografía de leonardo da vinci que es la
personalidad que más admiro de toda la
historia porque lo hacía todo por las
mañanas se dedicaba pintadas a esculpir
anatomía a matemáticas a inventar armas
y artefactos para volar y por las noches
se quedaba despierto para estudiar las
estrellas
el de acuerdo con la biografía sigue la
estructura del sueño hoy conociera como
sueño polifásico específicamente bajo la
estructura de huberman es decir él
dormía 20 minutos cada dos horas y no
estoy diciendo que hagamos de esto
porque es una locura
pero si digo que en los tiempos modernos
hacer una sola cosa a la vez es un lujo
me pasa a ser consciente y el tiempo que
se había va de las manos
por ejemplo en las filas del
supermercado del banco del cine
porque llegaba a la taquilla y en lo que
la persona de enfrente decide qué
película ver y la computadora arrancada
hayan pasado cinco o diez minutos
después llegaba las palomitas y en lo
que el amiguito me recomendaba el
paquete grande el extra grande y el
jumbo
y han pasado otros cinco o diez minutos
pero todavía han ido a ver la película
porque me faltaban 30 minutos de
comerciales
aprovechando este tiempo y a otros
parecidos a través de aplicaciones para
el celular que hoy son gratis puede
aprender francés y pudimos intercambio a
francia dos años
y ella estaba muy contento y dije igual
voy a hacer un cambio de imagen voy a
ganar masa muscular y empiezo una dieta
hipercalórica que me pedía comer cada 23
horas y nada mal entienda no es que no
me gusta cocinar pero eso de cocinar
durante unas dos horas para comerlo en
diez minutos
es algo que me tortura
y es por eso que una de mis comidas se
convirtió en un licuado de atún con jugo
de naranja y si bien delicioso de los
puedo apostar me proveía de la proteína
que necesitaba en 30 segundos
de vuelta en méxico volvió a aprender
que este es un país en que llegar tarde
es la regla y no la excepción
y es por eso que mi celular ahora cargo
siempre con libros en formato pdf para
ir leyendo a dos órbitas mientras espera
los demás
como último ejemplo
están ustedes para saber dónde yo para
contarlo pero a mi trabajo me hago de
tres a cuatro horas y de vuelta todos
los días
y es un tiempo que podría aprovechar por
ejemplo viendo un capítulo de mi serie
favorita en otro idioma por eso de
aprovechar las doble
o bien para realizar llamadas a amigos y
familiares
no puedo haber seguido pero con quién
desea mantener contacto
pero cuidado porque esto de ahorrar
tiempo es apenas el comienzo
por qué
hay que planificarlo hay que agendar
citas específicas con gentes específicas
a horarios específicos cursos
específicos porque si no va a llegar la
noche vamos a decir wow hoy a los de dos
horas ahora voy a echar en mi cama
desperdiciarlas todas de corrido
y es que asumir la importancia del
tiempo implica asumir la responsabilidad
de aprovecharlo
responsabilidad para con nosotros y para
con los demás
para con los demás porque muchas veces
damos por hecho de que por ser mi hijo
mi amigo mi esposa sentimos nos
pertenece no nos estamos dando cuenta de
que muchas veces más bien todas las
veces el tiempo que nos están dando es
algo que están dejando de vivir para
ellos mismos y nos la están entregando
literalmente están muriendo un poquito
por nosotros
responsabilidad para con nosotros mismos
porque así como los demás para
entregaron su tiempo mueren por nosotros
nosotros estamos alimentando el cliché
de que las redes sociales nos convierten
en zombies porque el tiempo que pasamos
dentro de una pantalla literalmente nos
está matando un poquito y este tiempo
néstor de tiempo es vida
y responsabilidad incluso para con
nuestro vocabulario
porque hablamos de matar el tiempo de
perder el tiempo de ser dueños del
tiempo de tener pasatiempos estamos
convirtiendo nuestro tiempo libre en
tiempo muerto y como toda muerte le
sigue un proceso de duelo completo con
sus cinco etapas
empezamos con negación
y diciendo nada es que todavía soy muy
joven todavía puedo seguir estudiando
todavía puedo poner ese negocio que
quiero todavía puede encontrar el amor
después sigue la ira y con el aire
vienen las culpas y dijimos no es que no
tengo tiempo para todos los procesos
burocráticos que me pide el gobierno
para poner ese negocio y si no tengo
tiempo para encontrar el amor porque mi
trabajo me exige demasiado
es que no tengo tiempo
y enseguida de eso viene la negociación
y negociar significa ajustar
porque empezamos diciendo quiero conocer
el mundo y después con el trabajo nos
damos cuenta de que apenas nos da unos
cuantos días libres al año decimos bueno
al menos quiero salir de la ciudad
pero después la rutina nos atrapa y lo
que queremos es encontrar tiempo para
dormir
eventualmente vamos a terminar diciendo
bueno al menos quiero salir de mi casa
eventualmente esto nos va a llevar a una
etapa de depresión de la cual no vamos a
salir hasta encontrar la aceptación
y aceptaciones a entender que lo
maravilloso de la inminencia de la
muerte es que nos permite disfrutar
plenamente lo que estamos viviendo
porque tal vez esta sea la última vez
que podamos hacer lo que estamos
haciendo
aceptación de que el tiempo es como un
río que corre y de cual es cierto
podemos tomar de él y beber pero no
podemos guardar agua para después y es
cierto que la mucha agua por correr pero
como dice el refrán
agua pasada no mueve molinos y es por
eso que creo que soñar y materializar
sueños es un asunto de rebeldía
porque implica salir de la zona de
confort que nos ofrecen la nostalgia y
la esperanza para vivir realmente el
presente
porque implica arrancar minutos incluso
horas cuando es necesario y convertirlas
en algo extraordinario como quien
extraiga una sublime escultura de una
vulgar roca porque aceptémoslo lo
aprovechemos o no el tiempo de todos
modos va a pasar
porque agradezcamos a nuestros seres
queridos el tiempo que nos otorgan o no
el tiempo de todos modos va a pasar
soñar y materializar sueños en serio es
un asunto de rebeldía porque implica
pararse de frente al tiempo y decirle
tú no detendrá su paso
yo no detendré mis sueños gracias
[Aplausos]